My name's Adam, I'm 34, and I hail from Melbourne in Australia.
我叫亚当，今年34岁，来自澳大利亚墨尔本。
I've just serendipitously been re-watching the show for the upteenth time, and I quite literally grew up on how I met your mother.
我最近非常偶然地又把这部剧重温了无数遍，可以说是看着《老爸老妈浪漫史》长大的。
This re-watch has been an interesting one, because unfortunately I'm in the midst of a separation.
这次重温感觉挺不一样的，因为不幸的是，我正处于分居的阶段。
My partner and I were together for almost 14 years, and we've been best friends since high school, 20 plus years at this point, so it's been a really trying and difficult time but man am I glad your show is around.
我和伴侣在一起快14年了，从高中起就是最好的朋友，到现在已经20多年了，所以这是一段非常煎熬和艰难的时期，天哪，真庆幸有你们的节目在。
It's strange watching it now I suppose being newly single and heartbroken but it seems apt given the themes and context of your show and I can't thank you enough that it exists because it's getting you through a lot and I really appreciate it.
我想，现在看这部剧感觉挺奇怪的，因为我刚恢复单身、心碎不已，但考虑到你们节目的主题和背景，又觉得再合适不过了。我太感谢它的存在了，因为它陪我度过了很多难关，我真的非常感激。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
I'm alone.
我孤身一人。
I'll be soon.
不久之后。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
When I see you.
当我见到你时。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我在纽约市把一切都告诉你。
Well.
好吧。
Hello.
你们好。
Welcome.
欢迎。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收听《我们是如何创作老爸老妈浪漫史的》。
I'm a very under the weather.
我是身体非常不适的。
Joshua Adner and I am here with a much healthier Craig Thomas.
约书亚·阿德纳，今天和我一起的是健康得多的克雷格·托马斯。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
I feel bad.
我感觉很不妙。
You feel like absolute crap today.
你今天看起来糟透了。
But God bless you.
不过上帝保佑你。
I must have had some bad milk.
我一定是喝了变质的牛奶。
We're right in.
我们直接切入主题吧。
You bury the lead.
你把最重磅的料提前爆了。
You're doing just fine.
你现在状态挺好的。
I don't know what's going on.
我不知道是怎么回事。
I did.
我确实。
I woke up, uh, not at my best, but I'm pushing through because it's showbiz kid, you know, showbiz for nobody show must come on.
我醒来时，呃，状态不是最好，但我还是在坚持，因为这就是演艺圈，孩子，你知道的，没有人会管演艺圈，秀必须继续。
We are talking about the episode milk today, which Josh's joke.
我们今天要聊的是“牛奶”这一集，用乔什的玩笑来说。
How I made your mother season one episode 21 Which aired when Ellen and on May back in the day back in the day and on May 8th in slight correction for last week For my own damn episode best prom ever.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季第21集，当年是在什么时间播出的来着？当年是在5月8日播出的。对上周的节目做个小纠正，为了我该死的最佳舞会那一集。
I might have said June 1st.
我当时可能说成了6月1日。
It was May 1st I don't know what I said, but here's a correction if I did this one was May 8th 2006 yes, and I should point out that this is this there's a very very hot sexy cameo and Oh, we'll get to that.
其实是5月1日，我不知道自己当时说了什么，但如果说错了，这就是纠正，这一集是2006年5月8日播出的，是的，我得指出，这里有一个非常非常火辣性感的客串，哦，我们会聊到那点的。
We'll get to that, Craig.
我们会聊到那点的，克雷格。
But I gotta say, when I asked you guys, what episode is next?
但我得说，当我问你们，下一集是什么时。
And you wrote milk.
你们写了“牛奶”。
And I was like, what the hell is milk?
当时我就想，牛奶到底是个什么鬼？
Like every episode of season one, I remembered the title vividly.
就像第一季的每一集一样，我对剧名记忆犹新。
And the title clicked.
然后剧名一下子在我脑海里连上了。
Oh, that's what that's about, milk?
哦，原来那一集是关于这个的，牛奶？
Like I did not remember that this episode was called milk.
我当时根本不记得这一集叫“牛奶”。
Would you today call this episode milk?
如果让你今天来定名，你还会把这一集叫“牛奶”吗？
No, it's definitely, I definitely wouldn't.
不会，绝对不会，我肯定不会。
I didn't come up with a better one while watching.
我在看的时候也没想出一个更好的。
That's the thing, I didn't really come up with a better one while watching it, but I like how many milk is a big metaphor.
关键是，我在看的时候确实没想出一个更好的名字，但我挺喜欢“牛奶”作为一个重要隐喻的设定。
It's a big metaphor in this one, milk.
在这一集里，“牛奶”是一个很大的隐喻。
The idea of the milk and milk becomes code for Lily's escape to San Francisco or not.
牛奶的概念，以及牛奶成了莉莉逃往旧金山与否的代号。
So it had, it plays a role in the episode, but yeah, I think it's, I don't not think it's the catch you settle.
所以它在这一集中起到了作用，但是，是的，我觉得它不如“将就”那么抓人。
Let's spend this hour trying to think of a better title as we go.
让我们花这一个小时边聊边想一个更好的名字吧。
And I would definitely call the one, the finale of this season, which is called Come On, which I think is also not that memorable.
我绝对会把这一季的最后一集命名为，也就是叫“来吧”，我觉得那个名字也不太好记。
should have been called like the rain dance.
本来应该叫“求雨”之类的。
Or, you know, they take the thing you're most gonna remember and make that the title, but I don't know what that is for this one.
或者，你知道的，把观众最能记住的那点拿来当剧名，但我不知道这一集对应的是什么。
Let's, we'll figure it out.
没关系，我们会想出来的。
Let's just recap, like give a quick sketch of what happens in this episode.
我们先回顾一下，简单概述一下这一集发生了什么。
So we're really hurtling towards the end here.
所以我们真的在全速冲向这一季的尾声了。
This is the second to last episode or the season one.
这是第一季倒数第二集。
Yeah, what do we got?
是的，我们都有什么？
What's happening here?
这里发生了什么？
So I'm also just thinking about it.
我也在想这个。
Maybe one other title could have been mistakes because this episode is about mistakes.
也许另一个剧名可以叫“错误”，因为这一集就是关于错误的。
Can we outsmart ourselves ahead of time about mistakes, or do we have to make the mistakes because that's living?
我们能提前靠小聪明避开错误吗？还是说我们必须犯错，因为那才是生活？
Can you think your way out of it ahead of time?
你能提前想办法摆脱困境吗？
And the answer turns out to be, no.
结果证明答案是，不能。
That's what this episode's about, thematically about what the actions of this episode are that Ted discovers that Lily is considering bailing on her wedding and going to San Francisco and doing this insane crazy thing.
这就是这一集的主题，从主题上讲，这一集的情节是泰德发现莉莉在考虑临阵脱逃不结婚了，要去旧金山做这件疯狂的事。
she has not told Marshall not insane crazy thing, doing this chasing her dream thing, doing something that matters to her in this sort of panic she's having about, is it all moving too fast?
她还没告诉马歇尔——不是疯狂的事，是去追逐她的梦想，在面对“这一切是不是进展太快了？”“我是在急速长大吗？”这种恐慌时，去做一件对她来说很重要的事。
Am I growing up too fast?
我是在急速长大吗？
And there's just this, to me, this is a great Ted Lilly episode because Lilly calls Ted in that moment.
在我看来，这绝对是泰德和莉莉关系很好的一集，因为莉莉在那一刻给泰德打了电话。
She has basically stolen Marshall's car to drive to this interview that if she gets it, she'll go to San Francisco for months during their wedding.
她基本上是偷了马歇尔的车去赶那个面试，如果通过了，她就会在婚礼期间去旧金山几个月。
And she calls Ted out and they have this amazing scene together, where Ted gets stranded on the side of the road.
她把泰德叫了出来，他们俩有一场精彩的对手戏，结果泰德被困在了路边。
Yeah, I really, this is actually one of my favorite kind of Ted Lillie moments of the whole series, just that she calls him, that they have it out and that she bails on him.
对，我真的，这其实是整部剧里我最喜欢的泰德和莉莉的时刻之一，就是她给他打电话，他们把话说开，然后她把他给甩在路边。
Anyway, I'm not doing a very good synopsis here.
总之，我这个剧情梗概做得不太好。
That's essentially the big crux of the episode is Lillie's fight-or-flight kind of response to getting married.
这一集的核心其实就是莉莉对结婚的“战或逃”反应。
And then the B-story is- Yeah, the B-ball, there's a couple other story threads.
然后B故事是——对，B线，还有另外几条剧情线。
There's a prank war at Barney's.
巴尼的公司里有一场恶作剧大战。
Marshall is interning at Barney's company and there's a prank war with someone in another Clark Butterfield, let's say the name.
马歇尔在巴尼的公司实习，他和另一个人之间展开了恶作剧大战，克拉克·巴特菲尔德，我们就叫这个名字吧。
It's a correct way which is by the way a huge Wesleyan reference.
这是一个正确的名字，顺便说一句，这是一个巨大的维斯大学彩蛋。
It is Clark Butterfield from the company Nicholson Hewitt and West.
他是来自尼科尔森、休伊特和韦斯特公司的克拉克·巴特菲尔德。
All of those are dorms at Wesleyan and every word of that is a dorm at Wesleyan University.
所有这些都是卫斯理大学的宿舍楼，这句话里的每一个词都是卫斯理大学的一栋宿舍楼。
Our alma mater, Carter and I and Alec Lev, our producer and my wife Rebecca, all of whom I met there.
我们的母校，卡特和我，还有亚历克·莱夫（我们的制片人）以及我的妻子丽贝卡，我都是在那里认识他们的。
By the way, fight or flight, she's fighting, she's leaving, they're fighting, put the two together.
顺便说一句，“战或逃”，她在战斗（fight），她在离开（flight），他们在吵架（fighting），把这两者结合起来。
That could have been, that could have been in fight or flight.
那也可以，那也可以叫“战或逃”。
We'll come up with, let's even come up with half a dozen better titles than milk.
我们要想出，哪怕想出半打比“牛奶”更好的标题。
That's the goal.
这就是目标。
We have two.
我们已经有两个了。
And yeah, so there's a prank war where Marshall's getting deeper into Barney's corporate culture, which is part of what's making Lily feel a little less close to Marshall lately.
所以，这里有一场恶作剧大战，马歇尔越来越深入地融入巴尼的企业文化，这也是导致莉莉最近觉得和马歇尔没那么亲近的原因之一。
And Ted also, sort of the sea story is the matchmaker we met earlier in the season, that company has come up with a perfect match for Ted that he misses meeting because Lily calls him away and then he gets rescued by Robin and it reawakens his feelings for Robin.
还有泰德，差不多算是C线故事，我们在这一季早些时候见过的那个红娘婚介公司为泰德匹配了一个完美的相亲对象，但由于莉莉把他叫走，他错过了见面，然后他被罗宾救了，这重新唤起了他对罗宾的感情。
Now we've really touched upon all these story threads of this episode.
现在我们真的把这一集所有的剧情线都串联了一遍。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I was two things that really jumped out at me.
好吧，有两件事深深打动了我。
I remember when I read it and when we maybe it was more when we acted it just the way that Allie did it, but I was always startled by and pretty delighted by the moment where Lily says, almost real quick, like in a rant, she says, and Ted, you're my best friend.
我记得当我读到剧本时，也许更深刻的是在我们演的时候，艾莉的表现方式让我大吃一惊，也感到非常欣喜，就是莉莉说出那句话的时刻——几乎是非常快地，像是一阵抱怨——她说：“泰德，你是我最好的朋友。”
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know why.
我不知道为什么。
I never, it almost changed my actor relationship to Lily, like Ted's relationship where I was like, oh, they're best friends, like Marshall and Lily and Robin, I mean, Marshall and Lily and Ted are all best friends, but Ted and Lily have a special thing even without Marshall.
我从来没有……这几乎改变了我作为演员对莉莉与泰德关系的理解，当时我想，哦，他们是最好的朋友，就像马歇尔、莉莉和罗宾——我是说，马歇尔、莉莉和泰德都是最好的朋友，但即使没有马歇尔，泰德和莉莉之间也有种特别的默契。
Like that is, that's their own thing that I feel like almost, you don't see a lot of it for a season, but they've known each other for so long.
就像那是他们两个人的秘密一样，我感觉几乎在第一季里你看不到太多这种情节，但他们认识太久了。
They've known each other since they were 18.
他们从18岁就认识了。
So you can imagine like, even as Marshall and Lily were falling in love all over college, like, Ted and Lily had late night talks too.
所以你可以想象，即使在马歇尔和莉莉在整个大学期间坠入爱河时，泰德和莉莉也会深夜畅谈。
Ted and Lily walked around and worked out life together.
泰德和莉莉一起走过，共同经历了人生的风风雨雨。
And you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
like it felt really, that felt really potent to me.
就像感觉真的很真实，我觉得那场戏真的很有感染力。
You played that as potent.
你把那种情绪演得很饱满。
You played that history, I think.
我觉得你把那种历史感演出来了。
I felt that history in that scene in a way that I hadn't before, that it really deepened the two of you.
我在那场戏里感受到了前所未有的历史沉淀，这真的让你们两个人的角色更加丰满了。
And you and Allison are good together.
而且你和艾莉森搭戏很有默契。
You know, we, there are like endless scenes of just the two of you and certainly not in season one.
你知道的，我们有无数场只有你们两个人的戏，第一季里当然也有。
And I feel like they've had these late night talks or these weird, you know, aside from Marshall before, I feel that in the history of how you guys played that scene.
我觉得他们会有这种深夜长谈，或者这些奇怪的……你知道的，除了之前和马歇尔在一起的时候以外，我觉得在你们演绎那场戏的历史中就能感觉到这一点。
But I feel like it's usually Lillie giving, talking Ted off some ledge.
但我觉得通常都是莉莉在付出，劝泰德不要做傻事。
And I love the nature of the scene where Lillie's essentially saying, it's my turn to climb up to the ledge and look down.
我非常喜欢这场戏的设定，莉莉基本上是在说：“轮到我爬上绝望的边缘往下看了。”
I'm always the one talking people off of there.
“我总是那个劝别人想开点的人。”
Right.
没错。
And also, who does she call?
而且话说回来，她打电话给谁？
Like she calls, it's like Ted's the break glass in case of emergency call for her.
就像她打给……对于她来说，泰德就像是“遇紧急情况时打破玻璃”的求救对象。
Yeah.
对啊。
Even though he's so close to Marshall, like I also, you know, I've observed about Ted observed about Ted in this first season, he is obsessed with plans, he's obsessed with order, he's obsessed with things going the way he wants, except when Robin comes in the picture, he'll rip up the plan, he'll rip up the party list, he'll do whatever, he'll improvise when Robin comes around.
尽管他和马歇尔那么要好，但我还……你知道的，我观察过泰德，在第一季里观察过泰德，他痴迷于计划，他痴迷于秩序，他痴迷于事情按照他想要的方式发展，除了罗宾出现的时候——只要罗宾出现，他就会撕毁计划，撕毁派对名单，随心所欲，随机应变。
But also, he's got this perfect gate lined up, like the perfect ordered like from his imagination.
但同时，他心里也勾勒出了一幅完美的宏伟蓝图，就像是从他想象中走出来的那样井井有条。
Weirdly, it's literally exactly what he's looking for and Lily calls any leaves and he goes to her.
奇怪的是，这简直完全就是他在寻找的东西，而莉莉一打电话他就离开，然后去找她。
So it feels like, yeah, Robin is the tantalizing object of his romance, but Lily in distress, or any of his friends in distress, are also enough to have him rip up the schedule and go to them, which I think is more evidence of when people ask me what they love about Ted, what I love about Ted, I often say his loyalty.
所以感觉就像，是的，罗宾是他浪漫情调中诱人的目标，但陷入绝望的莉莉，或者陷入绝望的任何朋友，也同样能让他撕毁日程表去找他们，我认为这进一步证明了，当人们问我他们最喜欢泰德什么、我最喜欢泰德什么时，我经常会说是他的忠诚。
What a good friend he is.
他真的是个好朋友。
you know he's such a good friend he's such a good friend and I love how you played that scene because Ted is the way I took it and tell me if this is how it felt acting it I took it that Ted was there for Lily because they are best friends but also I saw it in Ted's eyes your eyes and playing the scene that Ted knew he had to live with the heaviness of this knowledge that he couldn't share with his other best friend Marshall and I felt like I felt Ted torn between being there on the the side of that road in Westchester or Dutchess County, where he is, and thinking about Marshall back home.
你知道的，他真的是个极好的朋友，我太喜欢你演那场戏的方式了，因为在我看来——泰德去是因为他们是最好的朋友，你告诉我你当时演的时候是不是这种感觉——我是觉得泰德陪着莉莉是因为他们是挚友，但我也从泰德的眼睛里、从你的眼神和表演中看出，泰德知道他必须背负这个沉重的秘密，而这个秘密他又不能分享给他的另一个挚友马歇尔。我能感觉到泰德内心备受煎熬，一边要在韦斯特切斯特或达奇斯县那条路边陪着她，一边又在想着家里的马歇尔。
And the moment where he calls, where he has to actually talk on the phone briefly to Marshall, the guilt that he's talking to Marshall while he holds this terrible knowledge that Lilly is in this freakout that Marshall knows nothing about.
而在那个他给马歇尔打电话、必须跟马歇尔简短通电话的时刻，他一边怀着莉莉情绪崩溃而马歇尔一无所知的可怕秘密，一边跟马歇尔说话，那种内疚感……
I thought you played that great.
我觉得你演得太棒了。
There's like this real conflict, like conflicted energy to that scene.
那场戏里有一种真正的冲突感，充满了矛盾的情绪。
Is that how it felt to you?
你当时是这种感觉吗？
Like you were, you were trying to be the best friend to two people that the two missions didn't overlap I mean, for an actor, that's like a real gift, because it's like you wanna be pulled in three separate directions.
就像你在努力对两个人做好朋友，而这两个任务根本无法重合。我的意思是，对演员来说这简直是个天赋异禀的挑战，因为就像是你被三个不同的方向同时拉扯。
Like you want to feel that stress and strain of, and it's also true.
就像你想去感受那种压力和紧绷感，而且这也很真实。
I mean, I think we've all had experiences where you're in a group of friends or a trio or something and it's like the side group chat, right?
我的意思是，我想我们都有过这样的经历：当你身处一个朋友圈或三人小团体中时，就像是有一个私下的群聊，对吧？
Like suddenly there's information being exchanged that is not meant for the group at large, and then you have to hold that, you know.
就像突然间开始交流一些并不打算让整个团体知道的信息，然后你必须保守这个秘密，你知道的。
It's not quite, you know, someone's having an affair, but it is, it does feel like an infidelity to their plan.
这不太像是……你知道的，有人出轨了，但它确实感觉像是对他们原本计划的一种背叛。
You know, he's, she's really thrust this thing in Ted's lap, and you know what I thought was funny was when she said it might have a flat tire, and then Ted pulled up and and Jordana leaners she goes Ted can't change a flat tire but he's an architect so I feel like he has the brain to change but then he does but then he does the greatest acting that I probably did in the episode was acting as if I just changed a flat tire The kind of like, oh, okay, oh, there you go, mission accomplished.
你知道的，她真的把这摊子事扔到了泰德怀里，而且你知道我觉得搞笑的是什么吗，当她说可能车胎瘪了的时候，然后泰德把车开过去，乔安娜·莱纳就说泰德不会换备胎，但他是个建筑师，所以我觉得他有换备胎的头脑，但随后他确实……但随后他展现了我在这集里可能做过的最棒的演技，那就是假装我刚刚换好了一个备胎，那种“哦，好吧，哦，行了，任务完成”的感觉。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这个小约会，让你去纽约市散散心。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
Some people have just weird pockets of talent.
有些人就是有一些奇怪的特殊才能。
Like in two truths and a lie Ted would like throw in, can change a tire and people be like, that's a lie.
就像在“两真一假”的游戏里，泰德可能会随口说“会换轮胎”，然后大家就会觉得“那是假的”。
He's like, ah, no, it's a truth.
他就说：“啊，不，这是真的。”
I can.
“我会的。”
I'm from Cleveland.
“我是克利夫兰人。”
That was a great scene.
那真是一场精彩的戏。
I also love how early in the scene, Alison slash Lily starts tearing up, right?
我也很喜欢戏里刚开始的时候，艾莉森也就是莉莉开始眼眶湿润，对吧？
When she's almost starting to cry as she's saying, like, no, no, no, I just want to see if I can get this thing.
当她边说边快要哭出来的时候，就像是“不，不，不，我只是想看看我能不能拿到这东西”。
And then I'm going to let it go.
“然后我就把它放下。”
And I feel like she's crying because she knows she's lying.
我觉得她在哭，因为她知道自己在撒谎。
I love how she played that because she knows, she knows it's bigger than she just wanted to know if she could get it.
我很喜欢她的这种表演，因为她心里清楚，她很清楚这不仅仅是“她只是想知道自己能不能拿到”那么简单。
If she gets it, she's gone.
如果她拿到了，她就一走了之了。
She's going and she's pretending And if that's not true, and it's coming out of her eyes, that trying to hold that lie is coming out of her eyes.
她要走了，而且她还在假装。如果这并非出自真心，而泪水却从眼眶夺眶而出，那努力掩饰谎言的痛苦就化作了夺眶而出的泪水。
And I thought that was really excellent acting on her part.
我觉得她这部分的演技真的非常出色。
You know, once or twice a season, you guys really gave Allie like these kind of scenes where she would have like an aria or she would be like that, you know, that great rooftop scene with me and her later.
你知道的，一季里总有一两次，你们真的会给艾莉这类戏份，让她有一段独白，或者像后来她和我一起演的那场精彩的天台戏。
She just consistently is just extraordinary in these scenes.
在这些戏里，她的表现一直都是无与伦比的出色。
She's so good.
她太棒了。
I think because Ali is so kind of known for more like comedic things or quirky things like you forget like she's an A plus dramatic actress like she's so can break your heart.
我想可能是因为艾莉以往多以喜剧或古怪的角色为人熟知，所以你会忘了她其实是个顶级的戏剧女演员——她真的很擅长让人心碎。
And I don't know the way she delivered that mistakes thing.
而且我不知道她台词里讲到“犯错”那段是怎么表达出来的。
I was almost like I was really like just as an actor I was like that slaloming down that hill and clearing all those flags like when you're like, that's a real high level of difficulty what she did because it's a really hard speech in terms of just the logic of it.
我当时就真的像是个演员在看别人顺着山坡疯狂回转、避开所有旗杆一样，你会觉得：她做到的难度系数真的很高，因为仅从台词逻辑来看，这是一段非常难的独白。
And she's going too fast for Ted, but she herself had to understand it to memorize it, right?
而且她的语速比泰德还快，但她自己必须先理解才能背下来，对吧？
So I just thought she did an incredible job throughout that thing, you know, being being both like manic, but also having like deep clarity through it in her mania.
所以我只是觉得她在整段戏里表现得不可思议，你知道的，既表现得有点狂躁，又在狂躁中展现出无比清醒的认知。
It was really, it was a high level, a high wire act.
这真的是一个高难度的高空走钢丝表演。
There's like a deep self-knowledge there to say, essentially, damn it, I've made no mistakes.
里面有一种深刻的自我认知，基本上就是在大喊：“该死，我从没犯过错。”
This is the part where I get to at least flirt with making a big one.
“这是我至少能去跟犯个大错调情一下的部分。”
And then I'm not going to make it.
“然后我不会真的去犯它。”
I'll see if I can make it and then I'm going to let go of it and not make it.
“我看看自己能不能做到，然后我就把它放下，不去做这件事。”
And she knows she's lying there herself.
而她自己心里也清楚她在撒谎。
And she actually does have a point.
而且她其实也说得有道理。
I think people, the people who in their family or and their friend group are the person that kind of holds shit together.
我觉得人们……那些在家庭或朋友圈里承担着把乱摊子收拾起来的角色。
They're the cement, they're the load bearing support of the building, the building's gonna come down if you take away that piece, that wall, that column.
他们是水泥，他们是建筑物的承重支撑，如果你把那块砖、那面墙、那根柱子抽掉，建筑就会坍塌。
That's Lily, and I think she has been living under that pressure for her entire life.
那就是莉莉，我觉得她一生都在这种压力下生活。
I say this because some of this overlaps with my wife who was very much that and her family and friends and her family, with me and the kids, She's, some of this comes from her.
我这么说是因为这其中有些部分跟我妻子很像，她在她的家庭、朋友以及我们和孩子们的家庭里，非常扮演着这样的角色。
Some of these last couple of episodes of the season come from her.
有些情节就源自于她。
I will say that there were moments where she was like, that's really close.
本季最后这几集里的某些部分就取材于她。
You really didn't give me a heads up that the dialogue was going to be exactly stuff that I kind of wrestle with in my life, which was a lesson.
我得说，有时候她会觉得：“这也太像了吧。”“你事先也没提醒我，这些台词居然全都是我在生活中苦苦挣扎的那些事儿。”这可真是个教训。
Young Craig writer, young writer, Craig had to learn and really didn't and really just kept doing that, doing it the wrong way and like it would just air and people would go, oh, but I think that Alison plays that so well.
年轻的编剧克雷格，年轻的编剧克雷格不得不吸取教训，结果一开始没做好，还一直在用错误的方式继续写，直到它播出后大家纷纷感叹：“哦……”但我认为艾莉森把这个角色演得太好了。
because she's, I think Alison, she shares some of that in her energy in the world, I think, right?
因为我觉得，艾莉森在面对世界时的某种能量里，也带有这种特质，对吧？
And she shares on screen.
而且她在银幕上也展现了这一点。
That's how she feels to us.
这就是她给我们留下的感觉。
That's how that's her presence, her presence.
这就是她的存在感，她的气场。
She was also in the cast.
她在剧组里也是这样。
She was kind of the mama bear in terms of, I mean, Ali was definitely like, if I needed a doctor, or like, she just had a lot of answers to things of like, where you go when you need this, like, she's a mama.
她在某种程度上就像是个“老母亲”，我的意思是，艾莉绝对是那种——如果我需要找医生，或者诸如此类的事，她对各种事情都有很多门路，知道你需要的时候该去哪里找，她就像个妈妈。
She's a mama.
她就像个妈妈。
And I think that when you're the kind of hero child or the, you know, it's revealed later, like she had a very unstable childhood.
而且我认为，当你成为那种“被寄予厚望的孩子”，或者……你知道的，后来剧情揭晓了，她有一个非常动荡的童年。
Her father is this kind of not ball board game inventor.
她的父亲是个有点不靠谱的棋盘游戏发明家。
And, you know, she had to become an adult because she had children for parents essentially.
而且，你知道的，她不得不早早成熟，因为本质上她的父母才是需要被照顾的孩子。
And I think when you get those people in either duress or in therapy, there's a lot of dissembling to do.
我想，当你让这样的人处于压力之下或者去做心理治疗时，会有很多伪装需要卸下。
There's a lot of falling apart that has to happen because they have not been able to do that or allow, they feel like the whole structure will fall if they fall.
会有很多崩溃是必须要经历的，因为他们以前一直无法做到这一点，或者不允许自己这么做，他们觉得如果自己倒下了，整个结构就会分崩离析。
So it can be an enormous relief to have them do that, but also to them, it's like they're letting down not just themselves, but their whole world, they're holding up.
所以让她们宣泄出来可能会是一种巨大的解脱，但对她们来说，这就像是不仅辜负了自己，还辜负了她们苦苦支撑的整个世界。
And when you see that person and the audience sees Alice in that way, sees Lily that way, I think on the character see Lily that way, the audience sees Alice in that way.
当你看到这样一个人，当观众以这种方式看到艾莉森、看到莉莉时，我认为角色眼中的莉莉是这样的，观众眼中的艾莉森也是这样的。
When you see that person who's that sturdy, who's that necessary to keep the world, to keep the planet spinning and keep gravity working and people from flying off into outer space, when that person breaks, it's fucking, it's potent to go back to that word potent.
当你看到那个如此坚强、为了维持世界运转、维持星球旋转、维持重力存在、防止人们飞向外太空而必不可少的人崩溃时，那种感觉真他妈的……回到刚才那个词，很有感染力。
It's very potent when that person breaks, when that person cries, when that person has the breakdown in real life or as a character, it's very powerful.
当这样一个人崩溃、当这个人哭泣、当这个人在现实生活或作为角色发生精神崩溃时，那种冲击力非常强大。
It's almost unsettling to watch it, right?
看着这一幕甚至会让人感到有些不安，对吧？
unsettling to watch Alison slash Lily with this energy in this episode, unsettling in the best possible way.
看着艾莉森饰演的莉莉在本集中流露出这种情绪让人感到不安，但这是以最好的方式感到了不安。
I mean, like, and it's what makes this episode work and what makes what makes it special and some of the best acting in season one, I think, is that P dot sequence.
我的意思是，这正是让这一集奏效的原因，也是让它变得特别、成为第一季中最佳表演之一的原因，我认为就是那段P点序列。
And I also think the relative kind of swiftness of it, which is so startling to Marshall a little less to Ted just because he has more forewarning.
而且我也觉得这种情绪爆发的相对迅速，让马歇尔感到十分震惊，对泰德来说则没那么惊讶，因为他有更多的心理准备。
But like, the swiftness of it feels right because it's the simmering underneath, it's the, there is a snap, there's a kind of thing of like, I need to, I think she's looking at this road ahead and she's seeing all these other doors closed.
但这种迅速感让人觉得很真实，因为它一直在暗中酝酿，有一个突然爆发的临界点，就像是……我觉得她看着前方的道路，发现所有其他的门都关上了。
We've talked a lot about this.
我们讨论过很多次这个。
Like a lot about how I met mother, especially season one is about options.
比如《老爸老妈浪漫史》尤其是第一季，很大程度上是关于选择的。
You know, we have a lot of options, which roads are we gonna take?
你知道的，我们有很多选择，我们究竟该走哪条路？
And she literally like takes off on a road.
而她字面意义上地踏上了一条路。
She goes, she takes this car and goes, goes away.
她开着这辆车，头也不回地走了。
No one ever said Carter and I were subtle with metaphors.
从来没人说过卡特和我玩隐喻时会很委婉。
It's an actual road.
这真的是一条路。
Well, let's talk about you and Carter because this is a nice way to get into the film.
好了，我们来谈谈你和卡特吧，因为这是一个很好的切入这部电影的方式。
Oh, the other best acting of season one is this.
哦，第一季里另一个演技巅峰是这个。
This is two young studs that come into the bar.
这是两个走进酒吧的年轻帅哥。
So at the beginning of the episode, this is Ted's birthday, he's still wearing the crown.
所以在这一集开头，今天是泰德的生日，他还戴着那个皇冠。
He's still wearing his, yes, his crown.
他还在戴着他的，对，他的皇冠。
I understand Ted maybe wants to have his birthday party McLaren's but he's about to meet this perfect woman and he's like I know a spot come to McLaren's like he can't travel he really can't branch out he can't branch out at all that was just you guys didn't want to build another set for like a little it's probably been a want to build another it was definitely that although he never ends up going that date so it could have been anything we could have not built the set because he doesn't end up going I think it's the Ted wants to know this perfect woman fits immediately into his world maybe that's the logic and also probably a little bit not building extra sets so so Barney says he's got the best pickup line.
我理解泰德可能想在麦克拉伦酒吧办生日派对，但他正要遇到这个完美的女人，然后他说我认识个地方，来麦克拉伦吧，就好像他不能移动，真的不能拓展范围，完全不能拓展范围，那只是你们不想再搭一个场景，就为了短短的一段，可能本来就想搭另一个场景，绝对是那样的，虽然他最后根本没去那个约会，所以也可能是别的什么，我们可能没搭那个场景，因为他最后根本没去，我觉得是泰德想知道这个完美的女人是否能完美融入他的世界，也许这就是逻辑所在，也可能多少有点不想多搭布景，所以巴尼说他有最棒的搭讪绝招。
Is that what he says?
他是这么说的吗？
Like, I have the greatest pickup line of all time.
就像，我有史上最厉害的搭讪绝招。
The greatest pickup line of all time.
史上最厉害的搭讪绝招。
So they watch him do it.
于是他们看着他去表演。
He stops this woman and he says, Oh my God, you guys sit down.
他拦住这个女人，然后说，哦天哪，你们快坐下。
Oh my God, you're, please don't, don't, don't speak.
哦天哪，你们，求求你们，别，别，别说话。
You know, when he sits or down, calls the paramedics, Wendy, the waitress, this is the first episode where we say Wendy, the waitress.
你知道，当他让她坐下时，叫了急救人员，温迪，那个女服务员，这是我们第一次在剧中说出“温迪，女服务员”。
I think so.
我想是的。
She's, she's been in other episodes, but I don't know if we ever, yeah, it might have been like her name, her name, her curtsy She was great, but, and then these paramedics come in, and they're taking care of her, and he says what, you had a terrible fall.
她之前在其他集里也出现过，但我不知道我们有没有，对，可能就像她的名字，她的名字，她的屈膝礼，她演得很好，然后这些急救人员进来了，他们在照顾她，而他说什么来着，你摔得很惨。
Now, is that, I think it's like a young Brad Pitt?
现在，那个，我觉得他长得像年轻时的布拉德·皮特吗？
No, no.
不，不。
Now, who are those guys?
话说回来，那些家伙是谁？
Very, I mean, they must have gone on to other creators.
非常，我是说，他们后来一定去过其他制作团队吧。
Oh, the two actors?
哦，那两个演员？
I think they were the Leighton Book of Mormon.
我想他们演过百老汇的《摩门经》。
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。
No, that was Carter Bays and Craig Thomas, the paramedics.
不，那是卡特·贝斯和克雷格·托马斯，演急救人员的那俩。
Carter Bays and Craig Thomas, Very young I thought you guys look the same, but and then I saw you and I was like no you guys look younger I see Craig's old old fucking face of the podcast all the time.
卡特·贝斯和克雷格·托马斯，非常年轻。我以为你们看起来差不多，但后来我看到你，我就想，不，你们看起来更年轻。我总能看到克雷格那张老态龙钟的破脸在播客里出现。
It's different Yeah, no, we're young.
感觉不一样，对，不，我们很年轻。
We look very young Me probably 31 there.
我们看起来非常年轻，我那时大概31岁吧。
I'm thinking 30 31 car tonight We're our birthday's are six days apart in August, which is normal Pam Freeman was One or two days off me and It's a big Leo Munst and Sue Fetterman too, when we would all do one big birthday on the stage for all of us.
我想我30、31岁，卡特和我。我们的生日只差六天，都在八月份，这很正常。帕姆·弗里曼跟我只差一或两天才对。
Yeah, so you know what I like too about this Josh other than our moment of glory, Carter and I.
这也是个伟大的狮子座，还有苏·费德曼也是，那时我们会在舞台上一起为所有人过一个盛大的生日。
I like, Ted does the thing that you want him to do sometimes which is just get on board with enjoying something from Barney.
对，所以你知道我除了我和卡特的辉煌时刻之外，还喜欢这集的什么吗，乔什。
Not be like Barney, but he's like, as my birthday gift, you've been talking about this greatest pick up line of all time for months, presumably.
我喜欢，泰德做了有时你会希望他做的事，那就是顺便去享受一下巴尼带来的乐趣。
Let's see it.
不是变成巴尼那样，但他就好像，作为我的生日礼物，你几个月来一直在谈论这个史上最棒的搭讪绝招，大概是这样。
Let's see it for my birthday.
让我们见识一下吧。
And I enjoy that Ted is enjoying that.
为了我的生日，让我们见识一下。
I could make the argument that Ted enjoys Barney-isms when he's not thrust in the center of that, when he can watch the booth, he totally enjoys it.
我很喜欢泰德也乐在其中这一点。
But when it's like, you know, and he turns it on him, he's like, yeah, that's the difference.
我可以这么说，当泰德不被推到风口浪尖、当他能坐在卡座旁作壁上观时，他是很享受巴尼式的恶作剧的。
So this one, he can just be be an observer.
但当矛头指向他时，他就会觉得，好吧，这就是区别所在。
He can be a stat-learn Waldorf from the balcony and enjoy his hat.
所以这一次，他可以只是个旁观者。
So you guys had to chant, give her your number.
他可以像阳台上的两位老头一样作壁上观，享受他的帽子。
Give her your number.
所以你们当时得带头喊，把你的号码给她。
But I love that Barney starts his own chant.
把你的号码给她。
That was the writer's name, no, because if it's Barney under his breath, I give her your number.
但我喜欢巴尼自己带头起哄。
Come on.
那是编剧的名字，不对，因为如果是巴尼压低声音说，我把你的号码给她。
What's going on here?
拜托。
That was so funny.
这到底是怎么回事？
He played that so funny.
这一段太搞笑了。
But also Carter breaks.
他演得太搞笑了。
You didn't break.
不过卡特也笑场了。
Carter was smiling.
你没笑。
I took it very Seriously, I had a whole back story for my guy.
卡特当时在笑。
Yeah.
我当时非常认真，我为我的角色做了一整套背景故事。
Yeah, you were in.
对。
I really, I forgot.
对，你完全投入了。
Troilus and Krastina neighborhood playhouse is so funny.
我真的，我都忘了。
So funny, such a weird throwaway.
《特洛伊罗斯与克瑞西达》还有邻里剧场，太搞笑了。
We're just.
太搞笑了，真是个奇怪的随性梗。
But I promise I'm a plug.
我们只是。
He's like, if you do this, I'll plug your your Troilus and Krastina production to the bar.
但我保证我要打个广告。
Yeah, that's what they're getting out of it.
他说，如果你这么做，我就去酒吧帮你的《特洛伊罗斯与克瑞西达》制作宣传一下。
Yeah, paramedic one and two.
对，这就是他们从中得到的交换。
But I thought when I saw them come in, I was like, wow, the paramedics got here quick.
对，急救人员一号和二号。
And then I was like, no, they were waiting outside.
但当他们走进来时，我还心想，哇，急救人员来得真快啊。
They're actors that aren't right.
然后我又想，不对，他们一直在外面等着呢。
They were their actors.
他们是不对的演员。
Yeah.
他们就是演员。
And it had to have been a Monday night because it's their off night.
对。
It's their, it's their every day off.
而且那一定是个周一晚上，因为那是他们的休息日。
Yeah.
那是他们，那是他们的日常休息日。
Um, so when the waitress gets introduced, which, which again, like, copulates the town, like the Simpsons, you know, they're like, the small town.
对，嗯，当女服务员被介绍出场时，这又一次，就像《辛普森一家》那样构建了这个小镇，你知道的，他们就像是个小镇。
I love your point about that.
我很喜欢你关于这一点的看法。
I thought, um, touching the lasagna is so funny, like Lily has to touch the hot plate.
我觉得，嗯，摸千层面那一幕太搞笑了，莉莉竟然非要去摸那个热盘子。
Well, it's that theme.
嗯，这就是那个主题。
It's the mistakes.
也就是那些错误。
It's that thing of like, we know it's bad, but we have to do it anyway.
就是那种“我们明知这是错的，但还是非要做不可”的感觉。
And that's, yeah, that I like that theme really runs through the whole thing.
就是这样，对，我很喜欢这个主题一直贯穿整集。
I'm not sure the milk aspect of it is memorable enough to have been the title, but it's just that idea that we as humans, we know better and we have to make the mistake.
我不确定其中关于牛奶的桥段是否深刻到足以成为剧名，但它传达的就是那种理念：作为人类，我们明明懂得更好的选择，却偏要犯错。
It's just what it is, which I think holds up.
事情就是这样，我觉得这一点经得起考验。
I think it stands a test of time.
我觉得它经受住了时间的考验。
When you guys thought of a goat in the bathroom on the 30th birthday, is that something like just a challenge to yourself?
当你们在30岁生日时想出浴室里有一只山羊这个点子时，这就像是对自己的某种挑战吗？
Like in two years, if we're still around, we're gonna have to create a plot line about a goat in a bathroom.
就好像在说，两年后如果我们还在拍，我们就得创作一条关于浴室里有只山羊的情节线。
100%, we didn't know what we did not know what that was.
百分之百，我们当时根本不知道那是什么意思。
We just, we called our shot.
我们只是提前放话。
You paint yourself in that corner and go, when we get there, we have to do that.
你把自己逼入那个角落，然后说，等我们到了那个时候，我们就得这么做。
It's just, it's, it's a challenge accepted.
这就是，接受挑战。
It's a self challenge accepted.
这是一次自我接受的挑战。
And it's also a network.
这也是对电视台的一种表态。
Hey, CBS, don't cancel us.
嘿，哥们，CBS，别砍掉我们。
Yeah.
对。
People are going to want to see who the mother is and what the goat is on the 30th birthday.
观众会想看看30岁生日时的妈妈究竟是谁，那只山羊又是怎么回事。
So, so maybe the, like, do the right, do the writer's assistance, like, keep track of like, okay, season three is coming up.
所以，所以也许，比如编剧助理们，会负责追踪这些，比如，第三季快到了。
Ted's 30th birthday.
泰德30岁生日。
There has to be a goat.
必须得有一只山羊。
Is that how that works?
事情是这样的吗？
Yeah.
对。
We had a list of stuff to pay off, setups and pay offs, and consistency, and continuity.
我们有一张需要兑现的清单，包括伏笔和回收、一致性以及连贯性。
Yeah, we had a running thing and our wonderful writer systems would keep us honest on those.
对，我们有一个长期备忘录，我们优秀的编剧助理会在这方面帮我们把关，确保我们不会忘。
Still easy to forget, right?
但还是很容易忘对吧？
Two years away, he's 28, and this is the third year that you had to remember for two years.
还要过两年，他才28岁，这是你们需要为两年后记住的第三年。
You got to get to that goat thing.
你们得把山羊那事儿给圆上。
But yeah, it felt like a show, anytime you can do a thing, only your show can do it, right?
不过是的，感觉这是一部剧，只要你能做出只有你们的剧才能做出的事，对吧？
It's that future knowledge thing is a superpower of the show, and we were just like, let's have as much fun with that as we can.
这种对未来情节的预知可以说是本剧的超能力，我们当时就想，尽量在这上面多找点乐子。
We were second to last episode of season one, singing for our supper.
我们当时是第一季的倒数第二集，正在为生计卖力演出。
Yeah, that felt like flexing the time jump wings is more than ever in some ways.
对，在某种程度上，那种大跨度时间跳跃的感觉比以往任何时候都强烈。
We didn't know what it was, just to be perfectly clear.
坦白说，我们当时并不知道那到底是什么。
There was no master-minded, we didn't know what in God's name that was.
没有什么精密的布局，我们压根不知道那鬼东西到底是什么。
Do you know what I liked, and maybe it was the way I felt.
你知道我喜欢什么吗，也许这只是我个人的感觉。
I liked how effortlessly, joyfully Ted is wearing that crown.
我喜欢泰德戴着那个王冠时是那么自然、那么开心。
I don't know, I don't know, Lillie got him the crown or if he's like, get me a crown.
我不知道，我不知道是莉莉给他弄的王冠，还是他自己说“给我弄个王冠来”。
But there's something so funny about how he's just like, I'm the birthday boy, like, he's enjoying being the special birthday boy.
但最搞笑的是，他表现得就像“我是今天的小寿星”，他真的很享受这种当特别寿星的感觉。
It feels like the bride at the bachelorette party wearing the, whatever, the veil or whatever.
感觉就像单身派对上的新娘戴着什么面纱之类的一样。
Yeah, it's sweet.
对，挺可爱的。
I think Ted was a very good sport in this episode.
我觉得泰德在这集里表现得非常大度。
He was up for anything.
他什么都乐意尝试。
He's a good friend of Lillie and he, you know, he gets this very enticing thing and And he actually lets it go, whether or not that was a good idea, whether or not in that moment he could have known whether that was a good choice, I mean, maybe it was a mistake he had to make on theme, that idea of the love solutions thing coming back around, which I like.
”
他是莉莉的好朋友，而且你知道，他得到了这个极具诱惑的东西，但他最终还是放手了——不管这算不算是个好主意，不管他在那个当口能不能知道这算不算是个正确的选择，我的意思是，这也许是他必须犯的一个符合主题的错误，那就是那个关于“真爱解法”的梗又绕回来了，我挺喜欢这一点的。
I like that coming back around from earlier in the season, although it is one of the most dated feeling things in the entirety of season one, a matchmaker, because there's no apps for that.
我喜欢这个从本季早些时候再次呼应回来的梗，尽管红娘这个设定可以说是整整第一季里最显年代感的东西之一了，因为现在已经没有这种应用程序了。
I really like the guy who took over from Cameron Mannheim's role.
我很喜欢接替卡梅隆·曼海姆角色的那个人。
He's very dropped and he's super funny.
他非常随意，而且超级搞笑。
Is the reason not to have her back Bob Rorschach, by the way, was a great, that's a great name for him.
顺便说一句，不让她回归的原因是鲍勃·罗沙克，这是一个挺棒的名字。
Yeah.
对。
Is there, is the reason to do that plot wise, just it's easier to cast to not cast Cameron Manheim.
从剧情上来说，这样做的原因仅仅是因为不用找卡梅隆·曼海姆，所以更好选角吗？
It's just less expensive and a little easier.
只是更省钱，也稍微容易一点。
Yes.
是的。
It's way less expensive and scheduling and she was great.
这样便宜得多，档期也更容易协调，而且她人很好。
We would have, but it would have been one very expensive scene.
我们本可以请她，但那样会是一场非常昂贵的戏。
And sometimes, you know, we were a season one show.
而且有时候，你知道的，我们只是一部第一季的剧。
I also felt like Ted drove Ted Brodera's character.
我还觉得泰德把泰德·布罗德拉的角色给逼急了。
He broke her.
他把她搞崩溃了。
He broke the business.
他搞砸了这门生意。
100%.
100%。
百分之百。百分之百。
She loves the business.
她热爱这门生意。
She's like, if I can't find this guy a match, I have to tag it in, which sort of tracked.
她当时的想法是，如果我不能给这家伙找到合适的人选，我就得认输了，这倒也符合她的性格。
And she did, she was, she was a mess at the end of that episode.
而且她确实，那一集结束的时候她整个人都崩溃了。
So it does track.
所以这很符合情理。
She was like having an existential moment of the solo at the end of Matchmaker.
在《红娘》快结束时，她就像是在进行一场关于独唱的存在主义沉思。
I have a thing again about how I met your mother, having the best music taste.
我一直觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》有着最棒的音乐品味。
I love Kim Deal, Kim Gordon.
我喜欢金·迪尔、金·戈登。
This is what I was just gonna say.
这正是我刚才想说的。
The Kims, the Kims are name checked.
两位金，这两位金被点名了。
One of my favorite lines of Ted that they didn't put a laugh on because maybe it's not that funny, but I think it's so funny when he says, any Kim from any cool band can't be too picky, right?
泰德有一句我最喜欢的台词，剧组甚至都没在后面加罐头笑声，也许是因为它没那么好笑，但我就是觉得他说“任何酷乐队里的任何一个叫金的，都不能太挑剔，对吧？”时太搞笑了！
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Can't be too picky.
不能太挑剔。
Any Kim from any cool band.
任何酷乐队里的任何一个叫金的。
Like, that's just very smart to me.
我觉得这真的太聪明了。
It's a little people will dance that line.
这有点像人们会拿来开玩笑的梗。
It has the same feeling of that.
有着同样的感觉。
Yeah, it's the same.
对，是一样的。
So Kim Diehl from the Pixies, Kim Gordon from Sonic Youth, the fact that Ted loves cool bass player ladies is one of my favorite sort of low-key Ted traits and dreams.
所以来自小妖精乐队的金·迪尔，来自音速青春的金·戈登，泰德喜欢那些酷酷的女贝斯手这一点，是我最喜欢的泰德那种低调的特质和梦想之一。
And yes, name-checking them.
没错，点名提到了她们。
It's not like we played those band songs in this episode, but just name-checking them.
这倒不是说我们在这一集里播放了这些乐队的歌，但仅仅是点名提到他们。
We definitely had that feeling of like, they're not gonna say that on two and a half men at nine after us.
我们当时确实有一种感觉，比如，九点钟排在我们后面的《好汉两个半》里是绝对不会说这种话的。
And that King of Queens at eight didn't say it either.
八点钟播出的《皇后区之王》也没说过。
It's like it puts you in a sonic world.
这就像是把你带入了一个声音的世界。
Like it lets you know these are the music that's influenced them, that shape them.
就像是让你知道，这些音乐影响了他们，塑造了他们。
Jordana and I just saw the Broadway play John Proctor as the villain, which is excellent.
乔丹娜和我刚刚去看了百老汇话剧《约翰·普罗克尔是个恶棍》，非常精彩。
If you can see it, please do.
如果你有机会去看的话，请一定要去。
It's fantastic.
棒极了。
But it does a really great job of grounding these teenage girls like pop music as they're like almost like sacred texts, right?
它在表现这些十几岁女孩将流行音乐视作近乎神圣的圣经这方面做得非常出色，对吧？
right?
对吧？
Like Lord and Taylor Swift and Lizzo.
比如洛德、泰勒·斯威夫特和莉佐。
It shows that you remember when you love music as a high schooler, like the way we loved you two or something like that, and the replacements and things.
它展现了当你还是个高中生时对音乐的热爱，就像我们当年热爱U2或者雷普利斯乐队那样。
I think the music people love, especially at those tender ages, is very revealing about who you are and who you're going to become.
我认为人们喜爱的音乐，尤其是在那些青葱岁月里，能非常深刻地揭示你是谁以及你将成为什么样的人。
It's who you are.
这就是你的本色。
I just watched this Led Zeppelin documentary that came out recently, and I was like remembering what that band meant to me and I was like, this is like a core memory.
我最近刚看了这部齐柏林飞艇的纪录片，当时我就在回忆那支乐队对我意味着什么，我就觉得，这就像是一段核心记忆。
This is like a very formative, like, yeah, it's powerful and that's hearing the Kim's name dropped.
这是一种非常具有塑造性的经历，对，很有力量，听到金这个名字被提出来时。
I was very happy because he does create that world.
我非常高兴，因为他确实营造出了那种世界。
That's why you became a drummer and overdosed on drugs.
这就是为什么你成了鼓手并因为吸毒过量而死。
Yeah, that's it.
对，就是这样。
I said, my hero John Bond did that.
我说，我的偶像约翰·博纳姆就是这么做的。
I'm gonna do that too.
我也要这么做。
You know what, real quick, when the computer flashes and it lands on Ted, I love that it was just all crew members.
跟你说个有意思的，电脑屏幕闪烁并定格在泰德身上时，我特别喜欢那些照片全都是剧组工作人员。
That was entirely crew members of how I met your mother.
那全都是《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧组的工作人员。
I was just going to say, Josh, that this is a very cameo heavy of behind the scenes, how much I'm other people, because all of those crew pictures, me and Carter.
我正要说呢，乔希，这里面有好多幕后客串，全都是《老妈》剧组的人，因为所有那些工作人员的照片，我和卡特都在里面。
Rob Green, Reverend Rob Greenberg, marrying Ted and his future as an unseen wife.
罗布·格林伯格，牧师罗布·格林伯格，为泰德和他的未来隐形妻子主持婚礼。
Reverend Rob Greenberg, one of our, he's a writer and he's a producer.
牧师罗布·格林伯格，他是我们的编剧之一，也是制片人。
He was a consultant with us, the whole run of him, me and Rob Greenberg, It was in the writer's room part-time.
在整部剧的制作过程中他一直担任我们的顾问，我和罗布·格林伯格，他有一段时间是编剧室的兼职人员。
It was a pretty, just a one and direct with the only other director who directed a bunch of hymns than Pam.
这挺有意思的，除了帕姆之外，他是唯一一个执导过多集《老妈》的导演。
Rob is the best.
罗布最棒了。
As you can tell from his name, Rob is Jewish.
正如你从他的名字能看出来的，罗布是个犹太人。
So him playing a Reverend was deep, incredible character work on Rob's part.
所以让他扮演一个牧师，对罗布来说真的是一次深厚、不可思议的角色塑造。
Yeah, I mean, he's no paramedic number one, but are number two, whichever one I was.
对，我的意思是，他比不上急救人员一号，或者二号——不管是我们当中谁演的。
But it was number two, because Carter is alphabetically first.
但应该是二号，因为按字母顺序卡特排在前面。
That's probably paramedic number two, obviously, was the best acting in this episode.
那个急救人员二号显然是这一集里演技最好的。
Then Lily in that scene, then you in that scene, then Carter's fourth, Rob's a distant fifth.
然后是那场戏里的莉莉，然后是你，然后卡特排第四，罗布远远排在第五。
No, but yeah, so that was their, their hymnium behind-the-scenes people all over the place.
不，不过对，所以到处都是我们《老妈》剧组的幕后人员。
Yeah, I'm just making sure if we covered all my little, little notations.
对，我只是确认一下我们有没有漏掉我记下的那些小笔记。
A Luke and Leia, Ted says the skids are gonna be Luke and Leia, but there's a lot of pivotal things in this Penultimate episode of Season 1 here.
一个关于卢克和莱娅的梗，泰德说这两个孩子会像卢克和莱娅一样，但第一季这个倒数第二集里有很多关键的转折。
Had this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
遇到了这个老头，他……爱上了你，现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
Do you know what I thought about when Barney and Marshall start doing the White Mice prank on Clark Butterfield and those mice are climbing all over Jason?
你知道当巴尼和马歇尔开始对克拉克·巴特菲尔德搞“白老鼠”恶作剧，那些老鼠在杰森身上爬来爬去时，我想到了什么吗？
I was like, we had Jason handle a lot of wild animals in the show.
我就在想，我们在剧里让杰森接触过好多野生动物啊。
Don't you remember he had to hold like a, what was an armadillo or like some?
你不记得他得抓一只……那是什么，犰狳还是别的什么？
What was that thing he had to hold that was really hard to take?
他当时得抓什么东西，特别难拿来着？
It was hard for me to watch it.
我看着都替他捏把汗。
Oh man, I forget.
天呐，我给忘了。
Do you know what I'm trying to do?
你知道我在想说什么吗？
I'm completely blanking on this.
我这会儿脑子里一片空白。
A badger or something?
是一只獾还是什么的？
I mean, holy crap.
我的天啊。
Someone needs to write it and solve this for the older sins over here.
得有人写下来帮我们这群老家伙解答一下。
Yeah.
对。
In the comments, please remind me.
评论区里请提醒我一下。
I'm having a complete blank.
我脑子里现在一片空白。
Please remind us of what animal Jason held it later season, but I remember to do that.
请提醒我们杰森在后来的某季里抱过什么动物，不过我记得要去弄这事。
He really had to hold it.
他当时真的得抱着它。
animal trainer on set and he had to hold this like badger type animal yeah big memory and I'm not coming up with it that's so weird he had interact with monkeys at some point later yeah he did I will I will say that this prank war was a little bit um you know through season one of how much mother there was an elaborate prank war happening between us and the writers room of I think it was a show was called the loop it was a will gluck and handwriting might involved much other writers, and there was an elaborate, like, parts of whole days would go into having this incredibly elaborate prank war with the loop through this other writer's room, the couple buildings over from us.
片场有动物驯兽师，他得抱着这种像獾一样的动物，对，印象很深，但我现在想不起来了，太奇怪了，他后来还在某个时候跟猴子有互动，对，他确实有，我得说这场恶作剧大战有点……你知道的，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季期间，我们和编剧室之间进行了一场精心策划的恶作剧大战，我想那部剧叫《The Loop》，威尔·格拉克（Will Gluck）和一些编剧可能也参与了，那是一场精心策划的恶作剧，整整几天的时间都花在了跟隔着我们几栋楼的另一个编剧室的《The Loop》进行这种极其复杂的恶作剧大战上。
And I'm pretty sure that's, like, hours were spent on this prank war.
而且我很确定，像这样，花了好几个小时在这场恶作剧大战上。
It involved our agent, our agent Matt Rice was also the agent for, I think, one of the creators of that show.
它还牵涉到了我们的经纪人，我们的经纪人马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）也是那部剧的某个创作者的经纪人。
Literally, our agent was involved going both directions and helping them prank us and us prank them.
简直了，我们的经纪人两头跑，既帮他们捉弄我们，又帮我们捉弄他们。
It was, like, completely ridiculous us.
这简直荒谬透顶。
I think Chris Mill and Phil Lord were a big part of that because they were buddies with Will Gluck who's a very famous director now.
我觉得克里斯·米勒（Chris Mill）和菲尔·洛德（Phil Lord）在其中占了很大比重，因为他们和威尔·格拉克是好哥们，而威尔·格拉克现在是个非常著名的导演。
And yeah, so that was a, the prank war thing was definitely inspired by that.
所以，对，那场恶作剧大战绝对是受此启发。
You guys were so distracted by the prank war.
你们当时被恶作剧大战分了太多心。
That's why I ended up with lines like, that's New Year's Eve for you.
这就是为什么我最后会说出诸如“这就是你的跨年夜”这样的台词。
And when the circuits were jammed, yeah.
还有当电路出故障的时候，对。
That was part of the prank.
那是恶作剧的一部分。
They said, I dare you, well, can you get Josh Radner to say the the worst line in TV history, we said we can do it.
他们说，我敢打赌，你能让乔什·拉德纳说出电视史上最烂的台词吗？我们说我们能做到。
He's a really nice guy, that'll say the line.
他是个很好的人，他会说这台词的。
It's very amenable.
他非常随和。
Do you know what's one of my favorite lines of first season Ted that I got to say in this episode?
你知道我在这一集里得以说出的第一季泰德的最爱台词之一是什么吗？
Yeah.
对。
Can a brother go apple picking without getting the third degree?
难道黑人兄弟去摘个苹果还得接受严厉盘问吗？
Damn.
该死。
I know, I love them, yeah, that may have been my line.
我知道，我爱死它们了，对，那可能是我自己想出来的台词。
I love the damn, I love throwing a good damn at the end of something.
我喜欢那个“该死”，我喜欢在某些话的末尾加上一句漂亮的“该死”。
Damn.
该死。
And I love, you know, when Kobe shows up at the end, realize like Robin's been away most of this episode.
我喜欢，你知道的，当寇碧在最后出现时，意识到罗宾几乎缺席了这一整集。
You've mostly not seen her.
你基本上没怎么见到她。
She was off getting bad highlights in her hair.
她当时去弄砸了头发的挑染。
And that's another you know what?
这也是另一个，你知道吗？
You're good at acting, Josh Radner.
你演技很好，乔什·拉德纳。
So is Kobe Smolders and so is Lily Aldrin, Lily Aldrin.
寇碧·史莫德斯也是，莉莉·奥尔德林也是，莉莉·奥尔德林。
So is Allison Haddigan.
艾莉森·汉妮根也是。
You and Kobe, that scene in, there's a lot there's a lot that had to happen for Ted in this episode because leaving the lily thing in Robin's van, and having that scene with her that is so connected and at ease, and there's real chemistry there between Ted and Robin.
你和寇碧，在那个场景里，泰德在这一集中有很多事情要经历，因为把莉莉的事留在罗宾的车里，以及和她拍那场非常连贯、轻松的戏，泰德和罗宾之间确实很有化学反应。
That's a great scene too.
那也是个很棒的场景。
That whole sequence that ramps him up to making that decision of, I'm actually not gonna open door number three here and see what love solutions has to present me.
整段剧情推动着他做出那个决定：我实际上不打算在这里打开第三扇门，看看恋爱婚介所能为我提供什么解决方案。
I'm gonna stick with this, maybe a mistake, but I have to make it.
我要坚持这个决定，虽然可能是个错误，但我必须做出这个决定。
I have to sort of play this out and see if I can get this to happen at this moment in my life.
我得把这事进行到底，看看我能不能在我人生的这个阶段让它成真。
And damn it, next episode he pulls it off.
该死的，下一集他就成功了。
It's kind of like a great Ted Robin, almost like the end of Slutty Pumpkin, like a scene at the end of the episode where they kind of, you just see their easy chemistry and you see, you know, I have a friend who's married with three kids and he said to me once about his wife, he said, I knew when I married her that I would always be chasing her, that she would just be like an inch out of reach.
这有点像泰德和罗宾之间很棒的互动，几乎就像《性感南瓜》的结尾，也就是剧集结尾的那种场景，他们那种轻松的化学反应跃然纸上，你知道的，我有个已婚有三个孩子的朋友，他曾对我说过关于他妻子的事，他说，当我娶她时，我就知道我将永远在追逐她，她总是会离我只有一英寸的距离。
And they're still married, and I think they're happily married, but their dynamic is, he chases her.
他们现在还结着婚，我想他们婚姻美满，但他们的相处模式就是：他追逐她。
And I think that like, imagining Ted and Robin together in their future, I think that's what it would be.
我想，把泰德和罗宾的未来结合在一起想象，我觉得这就是他们未来的相处模式。
I think Ted would always be just a little more hungry for her, and she would be a little scared and a little out of reach.
我觉得泰德永远都会对她更加渴望一点，而她则会有点害怕，又有点遥不可及。
And then every once in a while, turn to him and surrender.
然后偶尔转过身向他妥协。
But there would always be this little chase, but there's something about Ted that he needs that.
但这种小小的追逐会一直存在，而且泰德骨子里需要这种感觉。
He needs to feel like he needs a project.
他需要那种感觉，他需要一个项目。
He needs a project.
他需要一个项目。
He's an architect.
他是个建筑师。
He needs a problem to solve.
他需要一个要解决的问题。
And that is some people's dynamic.
这就是某些人的相处模式。
And some people can have that dynamic for 70 years together.
有些人可以保持这种相处模式一起走过70年。
And some other people it will destroy things.
而对另一些人来说，这会毁了一切。
It just, it just depends.
这只是，这完全取决于个人。
I loved his, you know, joke, her joke about a candy and him going, candy was really sweet about the van and candy.
我喜欢他的，你知道的，那个笑话，她关于糖果（Candy）的笑话，然后他说，糖果关于货车和糖果的事真的很甜。
They were really sweet together.
他们在一起真的很甜。
The highlights joke.
挑染的笑话。
So scenes in between them.
所以他们之间的场景。
I think that they're, they're able to relax because there's nothing on the table right now.
我觉得他们能够放松下来，是因为目前没有什么好争执的。
Like in some ways it's like they've, they've moved past this thing.
就像在某种程度上，他们已经走出了那件事。
They've healed the kind of hurt around, or they're healing it.
他们已经治愈了周围那种创伤，或者说他们正在治愈。
This almost feels like the moment where they really do feel it.
这感觉几乎就像是他们真正有所感触的时刻。
But this is healing it.
但这就是在治愈。
Yeah, because in Best Prom Ever, there's that little moment at the end where she says, I maybe haven't forgiven you, but I miss you.
对，因为在《有史以来最好的舞会》中，结尾有那样一个小片段，她说，我可能还没有原谅你，但我很想念你。
And this is the next episode, right?
而这就是下一集，对吧？
This is them realizing they really, really, really like each other.
这就是他们意识到彼此是多么多么喜欢对方。
And also that Robin will go out of her way to help Ted.
而且罗宾也会不辞辛劳地去帮泰德。
I mean, Duchess County is a drive.
我的意思是，达奇斯县可有一段车程呢。
You know, it's like, she's got to change her night considerably after probably a long day.
你知道的，这意味着她可能在经历漫长的一天之后，不得不大大改变她晚上的安排。
Um, I love where we do a classic kind of Moseby hand on the heart when he sees her hair and her hair is objectively kind of ridiculous, but it also like, hey, he'll love her with that hair.
嗯，我喜欢当莫斯比看到她的头发时，做出了一个经典的捂胸口动作，而她的头发客观来说有点荒谬，但这也像是在说，嘿，就算她顶着这头发他也会爱她。
Like I think in some ways he realizes how much he loves her because it's like that that hair is not a deal breaker.
我觉得在某种程度上，他意识到自己有多爱她，因为这头发并不是决定分手的原则。
It's more like I'll move towards this, like this is great.
更像是，我会接受并走向这个，这太棒了。
It's a, it is a moment of surrender from her, right?
这是一个她妥协的时刻，对吧？
She takes off this, she shows him some vulnerability.
她卸下了防备，向他展现了自己脆弱的一面。
She shows him this ridiculous head of hair.
她让他看到了自己这个荒谬的发型。
She takes off some armor and says, look at me in an effort to cheer him up and send him on his way to maybe go meet this wonderful woman.
她卸下了盔甲，说，看看我吧，以此来逗他开心，送他上路去见那位美丽的女士。
And you sense in her like a little, she loves Ted there.
你能从她身上感觉到一丝，她在那一刻是爱着泰德的。
And there's a little something there.
那种感觉有点微妙。
There is a little something there in that scene between you two and he picks up on it.
你们俩的那场戏里确实有那么一点微妙的感觉，而他察觉到了。
She knows it's there.
她知道那种感觉存在。
And she's a little wistful that maybe he's going off to meet the perfect woman.
而且她有点怅然若失，也许他是去见那个完美的女人。
She had feelings for him.
她对他是有感情的。
She called them after 2 a.m.
她过了凌晨两点还给他打电话。
Scoreboard.
记分牌上见分晓。
But in love, there's always those moments where you have to reveal whether it's an emotional kind of scar or like a physical thing you're uncomfortable with.
但在爱情中，总会有这样一些时刻，你必须袒露自己，无论是情感上的伤疤，还是让你感到不适的外在。
The love is about like, look at this part of me.
爱情就是关于“看看我身上的这一部分”。
Do you love this part of me?
你爱我身上的这部分吗？
Were you except this part of me?
你会接受我身上的这部分吗？
And she's doing that.
而她正在这么做。
Obviously, it's something that can be remedied, you know, she can get her hair fixed, but it's vulnerable and it's a point of real connection to bid for affection from her, and he really gives it to her.
当然，这其实是可以弥补的，你知道的，她的头发可以修好，但这很脆弱，这是为了从他那里换取爱意而进行的一次真正的连接，而他也确实给予了她回应。
But also, I want to say that so the scripts go out to the actors, but it also goes out to all the department heads, right?
不过我也想说，剧本会发给演员，但也会发给所有部门主管，对吧？
Hair, makeup, wardrobe.
发型、化妆、服装。
So they have to look through props.
所以他们得浏览道具。
They have to look through and say, what is up ahead for us in this episode, right?
他们必须通读剧本并说：这一集里有什么在等着我们，对吧？
So Dave Baker and props will see, you know, we need this many drinks.
所以道具师戴夫·贝克（Dave Baker）会看到，你知道的，我们需要这么多杯饮料。
We need this party hats for Barney, although I don't know if I don't know if that would be wardrobe, that's probably props.
我们需要给巴尼准备这些派对帽，虽然我不知道这算不算服装，这可能属于道具。
But hair will have to see, okay, coping needs bad highlights, right?
但发型还得再看看，对吧，对付这些需要不好的挑染，对吧？
So they have to figure out like how to give her lots of conversations, the strengths of hair, right?
所以他们得琢磨怎么给她安排很多对话，展现发型的优势，对吧？
So just when we talk about like the show being created, all of this stuff has different departments that are, you know, they're all serving the story, but they each have their own areas of concern that they really have to tend to.
所以，当我们谈论这部剧的创作时，所有这些东西都有不同的部门，你知道的，它们都是为故事服务的，但它们各有各的关注点，必须切实去处理。
and get ahead of, yeah.
并且要走在前面，是的。
And this is an episode where we had to, on a sound stage, have enough room for a fiero to break down on the side of what looks like a road outside.
在这一集中，我们必须在摄影棚里留出足够的空间，让一辆菲亚特在看似室外的路边抛锚。
And then at some point, drive away.
然后呢，在某个时刻开走。
We did that on the stage next door, I believe, right?
我们是在隔壁摄影棚拍的那个，我没记错吧？
The stage next, you beat me to the punch.
隔壁摄影棚，你抢我的台词了。
I think this is the first time we had to go to that next door stage and create a big open set.
我觉得这是我们第一次去隔壁的摄影棚搭一个很大的开放式场景。
And there's some other great scenes in the history of him where we did that, that stage next to us not eternally occupied by another show a lot of our runs.
剧中还有一些其他很棒的场景也是这么拍的，在我们拍摄的大部分时间里，隔壁那个摄影棚并不总是有别的剧组在用。
We were able to sometimes just grab it and say we have a big, we need to set big enough for a fiero to pull away.
我们有时可以直接把它占下来，说我们需要一个大场景，大到足够让一辆菲亚特开走。
A shot wide enough.
需要一个足够宽的镜头。
And so that's a much bigger project for everybody.
所以这对每个人来说都是一个大得多的项目。
Cost more money.
花钱更多。
It's a bigger set.
这是一个更大的布景。
Huge, you know, foresight is needed to sort of plan that one moment where that car drives away, but we did it.
你知道的，需要巨大的远见来规划车开走的那个镜头，但我们做到了。
That's all on stage 21 right next to stage 22, our home stage.
那些都在21号摄影棚拍的，就在我们的大本营22号摄影棚隔壁。
And yeah, it took more work to get that shot, but it was great.
是的，拍那个镜头花了不少功夫，但效果很棒。
I'll just say one last thing that I thought the key line, at least for Ted in this episode, is I don't want perfect.
我最后说一点，我认为对泰德来说，至少在这集中最关键的一句台词是：我不要完美。
I want Robin.
我要罗宾。
And I think that it's evidence of his growth that his own plans and his own idea of perfection is actually maybe not even what he's looking for.
我认为这证明了他的成长，他自己的计划和对完美的构想，其实可能甚至不是他真正在寻找的东西。
You think you want one thing and then you fall in love.
你以为你想要一样东西，然后你坠入爱河。
I mean, it's not just people like you, there's like real estate, you know, you, you think you're looking for one place, you walk into a house or an apartment, you go, no, this is my, this just is my, this is where I'm going to live.
我的意思是，不只是人，还有像房地产，你知道的，你以为你在找某个地方，你走进一栋房子或公寓，你会说，不，这就是我的，这就是我的，这就是我要住的地方。
And it doesn't have all the things I wanted, it actually has some things I didn't think I wanted, but actually are wonderful.
它并没有我想要的所有东西，实际上它有一些我以为我不想要、但其实非常棒的东西。
I think that he's learning that Robin's imperfection is perfect for him.
我觉得他正在明白，罗宾的不完美对她来说才是完美的。
That's wisdom, I think, right?
我认为这是智慧，对吧？
I think there's there's wisdom in that line.
我觉得那句台词里蕴含着智慧。
I think the audience, some of the audience is probably screaming at the to screen like a horror movie don't go in there like hey what are you doing go meet the woman go see what's behind door number three love solutions lady and maybe that's true but Ted is experienced I think he's gaining some wisdom there in a sense because he's saying I've spent so much time chasing this notion of perfect I'm gonna forget about that and just see what's right in front of me and see if I can make that finally happen and make what's actually in my life happen rather than something some tantalizing other floating abstractly outside of the perimeter of my life, this promise of something perfect that a computer is serving up.
我想观众里有的人可能在冲着屏幕大喊，就像看恐怖片一样：别进去！嘿，你在干嘛？去见那个女人啊，看看三号门后面是什么！爱情解方女士。也许确实如此，但泰德经历了这一切，我觉得他在某种意义上获得了一些智慧，因为他在说：我花了那么多时间追逐这个完美的观念，我要把它忘掉，只看看眼前有什么，看看我能不能最终实现它，让生活中真实存在的事物发生，而不是去追求那些虚无缥缈、盘旋在我生活边缘的诱人幻影，那种由电脑端出来的完美承诺。
Maybe that's something, maybe it's not, but I want to see through my actual life right here.
也许那是某种东西，也许不是，但我想要看清我当下真实的生活。
This is my life right in front of me.
这就是我眼前的生活。
I think there's wisdom there.
我觉得这里面有智慧。
I think I got a great piece of advice when I was having trouble letting go of how I thought something big in my life was going to go and it didn't go that way, which was really mourning the thing.
我想我曾得到过一个很好的建议，当时我很难放下我对生活中某件大事本该如何发展的执念，但事情并没有那样发展，当时我真的在为那件事哀悼。
Having a little funeral in in your mind for the thing you thought was going to be this perfect situation and let go of it and really put it to bed, like really say, I'm not going to pretend things were going to be perfect, that that's possible, I'm just going to actually live the life I'm living.
在心里为那件你以为会是完美局面的事情举行一个小小的葬礼，然后放手，真正地把它安葬，也就是对自己说：我不再假装事情会是完美的，那是不可能的，我只是去过我真正正在过的生活。
And that's how in so many different categories in life, I think that's great advice actually.
我觉得在生活的许多不同层面上，这都是一条极好的建议。
I mean, regardless of what goes on, it happens with Ted and Robin, I think really deciding that the chase for perfect is a road to madness and that wisdom lies in actually living the life you're living, I think there's definitely something there.
我是说，不管发生什么，泰德和罗宾之间也是如此，我认为真正认定对完美的追逐是一条通往疯狂的道路，而智慧在于真正过好你当下的生活，这里面绝对是有道理的。
I love how Ted, when everyone groans and reacts and says no, not again, and he is completely unaffected by it.
我太喜欢泰德了，当所有人都发出呻吟和反应，说“不，又来”时，他却完全不受影响。
He just has such inner calm and serenity and knowing about it that nothing can rattle him.
他内心有着如此的平静、安宁和笃定，没有什么能动摇他。
This is going to happen.
这事就要发生了。
Yeah, and it carries over into the next episode.
对，而且这种状态延续到了下一集。
I love confident Ted.
我喜欢充满自信的泰德。
Ted is actually tuning into some universal vibration here in this episode because he goes there to help Lilly, that falls apart, Robbins there to help him.
泰德在这一集里其实是接上某种宇宙的共振了，因为他去那是为了帮莉莉，结果搞砸了，罗宾在那儿帮他。
Everything's there in his life, right?
他生活中的一切都在那儿，对吧？
It's all there.
全都在那儿。
It's a closed circuit.
这是一个闭环。
It's there.
它就在那儿。
His life has what he needs in this episode and he knows that.
在这集中，他的生活拥有了他所需要的一切，而他深知这一点。
Well, I wonder, and I'm sure that on some level, this is true, but if Lillian Marshall can maybe not make it and get rattled.
嗯，我在想——而且我确信在某种程度上确实如此——莉莉和马修也许会挺不过去并阵脚大乱。
Nothing is certain.
没有什么什么是确定的。
There is no order.
没有什么秩序可言。
There is nothing we can really depend on.
没有什么我们可以真正依赖。
You might as well follow your heart and see where it leads.
你不如顺从你的内心，看看它会把你带向何方。
And I love that last conversation about milk to bring us back to the maybe perhaps missed title.
我喜欢最后关于牛奶的那段对话，把我们拉回了那个也许被忽略了的剧集标题。
But Lillian Tedder actually having a telepathic conversation there.
但莉莉和泰德其实在那里进行了一场心灵感应般的对话。
They're just having a different conversation for Marshall.
他们只是在和马修进行一场不同的对话。
I think Ted is seeing the imperfection of the perfect couple.
我觉得泰德看到了完美情侣的不完美之处。
It's the perfect couple.
这就是那对完美情侣。
He's been trying to replicate this perfect couple and he's seeing that there is imperfection in this perfect couple and his best friend Marshall doesn't know that his other best friend Lily is experiencing something very unsettling and I think that's right.
他一直在试图复制这对完美情侣，而他现在看到这对完美情侣其实也有不完美的地方，他的好朋友马修并不知道他的另一个好朋友莉莉正在经历一些非常让人心神不宁的事情，我觉得这很对。
I think that gives Ted free rein to go chase what could be imperfect for him.
我觉得这给了泰德全权去追求对他来说可能并不完美的事物。
but it's what he wants and it's what he needs to see through.
但那是他想要的，也是他需要亲历的。
And that's our season finale.
这就是我们的季终集。
Very next episode.
紧接着下一集。
We're almost at the end of season one of both the TV show and the podcast.
无论是这部电视剧还是这个播客，我们都快要迎来第一季的尾声了。
You really teed up a finale really beautifully here.
你真的把季终集铺垫得非常精彩。
So it definitely makes me want to tune in and watch the finale and we'll be discussing it next week and I'm really looking forward to it.
这绝对让我很想收看大结局，我们下周会讨论它，我真的很期待。
Well, we've come to the end of the show and we like to end this show and every show with a letter that we've received.
好了，节目接近尾声了，我们习惯用一封收到的来信来结束本期以及每一期节目。
If you would like to write us a letter or record a voice note about what how I met your mother means to you or what your relationship has been to the show, please go to how we made your mother dot com h w m y m dot com.
如果你想给我们写信，或者录一段语音留言，聊聊《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么，或者你与这部剧有什么样的羁绊，请访问 how we made your mother 点 com，即 hwmym 点 com。
Go to contact and follow the instructions there should be pretty clear.
点击联系我们，按照上面的说明操作，应该非常清楚。
But we've just gotten flooded with beautiful reflections and people letting us know how this show came to them and how it's changed them and affected them.
不过我们已经收到了大量美好的感悟，大家纷纷告诉我们这部剧是如何走入他们的生活，又是如何改变和影响他们的。
And we have a beautiful letter to read today.
今天我们有一封非常美妙的信要读。
This is from Howard in Taiwan.
这是来自台湾的霍华德（Howard）写的。
I want to tell you a story about my soulmate, the one true love of my life.
我想给你们讲一个关于我的灵魂伴侣、我生命中唯一的真爱的故事。
The first time I met my girlfriend was during our freshman year of college.
我和女友第一次见面是在我们大学一年级的时候。
She had already watched how I met your mother multiple times, but she was the one who introduced me to the show.
她当时已经看过好几遍《老爸老妈浪漫史》了，但正是她把我带入了这部剧。
We shared many of the same thoughts about himium which helped us build a wonderful connection.
我们对这部剧有着许多相同的看法，这帮我们建立了一种奇妙的连接。
Thank God we were like Lily and Marshall to people who found true love from the very beginning.
谢天谢地，我们就像从一开始就找到真爱的人心中的莉莉和马修一样。
By the end of this year we will be celebrating our six-year anniversary.
今年年底我们将庆祝我们在一起六周年的纪念日。
Now I'm about to pursue my master's degree in the US.
现在我即将去美国攻读硕士学位。
Sometimes I feel like it's a mistake because I'm deeply in love with my girlfriend, my country, Taiwan, and every single friend I have there.
有时我觉得这是一个错误，因为我深深地爱着我的女友、我的祖国台湾，以及我在那里遇到的每一个朋友。
Studying abroad could easily weaken or even break those relationships.
出国留学很可能会削弱甚至切断这些关系。
However, I still need to go ahead to find out if this path is truly worth it for me.
然而，我还是得勇往直前，去看看这条路对我来说是否真的值得。
This situation reminds me of Lily in episode 21, when she wanted to find out if she was meant to pursue her dream of becoming an artist.
这种情况让我想起了第21集里的莉莉，当时她想弄清楚自己是否应该去追求成为艺术家的梦想。
In that episode, she stood in the middle of nowhere and told Ted, I know it's a mistake, but there are certain things in life where you know it's a mistake, but you don't really know it's a mistake because the only way to know it's a mistake is to make the mistake.
在那一集里，她站在荒郊野岭对泰德说：我知道这是一个错误，但生活中有某些事情，你知道这是一个错误，但你其实并不真正知道它是错误，因为知道它是错误的唯一方法就是犯下这个错误。
And then you look back and and say, yep, that was a mistake.
然后你回过头来说，没错，那确实是个错误。
So really, the bigger mistake would be to not make the mistake, because then you'd go your whole life not really knowing if something is a mistake or not.
所以实际上，更大的错误是不去犯这个错误，因为那样你就会一辈子都不知道某件事到底是不是错误。
Thank you again to this show for giving me the courage to pursue my dreams and to my girl.
再次感谢这部剧给了我追求梦想的勇气，也谢谢我的女孩。
By the time you reach this episode, I will probably be in a graduate program in the US.
当你们听到这一集的时候，我可能已经在美国的某个研究生项目里了。
So I want to tell you, don't be afraid.
所以我想对你说，不要害怕。
We can make it through this.
我们一定能熬过去的。
Wait for me.
等我。
Love you, my dear Anna, Howard.
爱你的，我亲爱的安娜，霍华德。
Wow.
哇。
Jordana's crying.
若妲娜哭了。
Usually the beginnings of the episodes makes me, I hear it, Jordana, Josh's life, Jordana, is crying in the background from that letter.
通常节目的开头会让我……我听到背景里若妲娜在因为那封信而哭泣。
That letter's unbelievable.
那封信太不可思议了。
Oh my God, that got her, that got me too.
哦天哪，感动了她，也感动了我。
Wow, thank you for sharing that, Howard.
哇，谢谢你分享这个，霍华德。
Beautiful, that's a beautiful, oh my God, I so hope that she hears this, that this is a surprise to her that she hears this.
太美好了，这是一封美好的信，天哪，我太希望她能听到这个，希望这对她来说是个惊喜。
If Anna's not, if Anna's not in the business of listening to the C block, you gotta remind her.
如果安娜平时不听C段的内容，你得提醒她一下。
Stay tuned to the end.
收听到最后。
Sits through the pretty letter ad.
听完那些动听的信件广告。
There's something really beautiful after it.
那之后会有非常美妙的事情。
We're gonna talk about cats peeing, and then you're gonna hear undying devotion from Howard.
我们接下来要聊聊猫咪小便的事，然后你们会听到霍华德永恒的深情。
That was so beautiful.
那真的太美好了。
I wish you guys the best of luck.
我祝你们好运。
I'm so glad the show speaks to you in that way.
我很高兴这部剧能以这种方式触动你们。
Oh boy, I think going to take that adventure is an amazing thing to do.
天哪，我觉得去开启那场冒险是一件了不起的事。
And I think you sound very in love and have a good feeling it's gonna go well like it did.
而且我觉得听得出你深陷爱河，我也有一种强烈的直觉，一切都会像当年那样顺利。
In the end, in the long run, there was some turbulence from Marshall and Lily, but spoilers, they were okay.
最终，从长远来看，马歇尔和莉莉之间虽然有过一些波折，但剧透一下，他们最后很好。
I gotta say, Craig, I enjoyed reading that speech from Lily a little slower than she delivers it.
我得说，克雷格，我很喜欢听你用比莉莉本人更慢的语速来朗读那段演讲。
There's a lot of wisdom in that speech.
那段演讲里蕴含着很多智慧。
And there's a lot of- There's a lot of wisdom.
而且有很多——有很多智慧。
She's manic.
她有点歇斯底里。
But she's also in some ways articulating core theme or philosophy of how we met your mother is like, you can plot everything out, but you've got to live it forward and you've got to step in the potholes and twist your ankle, you know, to learn and where you're going.
但她在某种程度上也阐明了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的核心主题或哲学，那就是：你可以把一切都计划好，但你必须向前生活，你必须踏入水坑、扭伤脚踝，你知道的，这样才能学会成长并找到前行的方向。
As you read it, which I enjoyed hearing you read that speech in a different tone and sort of it was like a good cover.
当你朗读它的时候，我很享受听你用不同的语调来朗读那段演讲，这就像是一次精彩的翻唱。
It was like you took a rock song and slowed it down to a ballad there, one of those.
就像你把一首摇滚歌曲放慢成了一首民谣，其中一首那种风格的歌。
And I thought of Jimmy Stewart and it's a wonderful life.
让我想到了吉姆·斯图尔特和《生活多美好》。
That's what I was thinking of as you were reading that because there's this kind of yearning and like, I've got to go out into the world, I've got to do these things.
当你在读那段话时，我脑子里想的就是这个，因为里面有一种渴望，就像是“我必须去外面的世界，我必须去做这些事情”。
But there's also this feeling of there's so much here for me.
但同时也有这样一种感觉：这里有太多属于我的东西。
There's so much here for me.
这里有太多属于我的东西。
And what a universal conundrum.
这是一个多么普遍的难题啊。
Do I go out seeking everything outside or do I realize I have enough here?
我是该出去寻找外面的所有一切，还是意识到我在这里已经拥有足够多了？
Sometimes you get to do both and it works out.
有时候你两者都能兼顾，而且结果很不错。
And I hope that's what Howard gets to go do.
我希望霍华德也能这样。
He gets to go see the world.
他去看看外面的世界。
on his world is still there waiting for him and with him through that.
而他的世界依然在那里等着他，并一如既往地陪伴着他。
And I think that to share that, to trust that person, to trust that your life and your world is going to be there on the other side is a huge and wonderful act of faith.
我觉得，能够去分享这一点，去信任那个人，去坚信你的生活和你的世界在经历这一切之后依然会在原地，这是一种巨大而美好的信念。
And I think that if you lose something or if something is shaken or challenged by that, that can also in the long run be a good thing and lead to something stronger on the other side, even if it's a little different than you thought.
而且我认为，如果你因此失去了什么，或者有什么受到了动摇和挑战，从长远来看，这也可能是一件好事，并能在经历风雨后孕育出更坚固的东西，哪怕它和你想的有点不一样。
So I just wish you the best of luck.
所以我只想祝你们好运。
I think it's brave and exciting and lovely what you're doing Howard, so thank you for sharing that.
我觉得你做的事很勇敢、很激动人心也很可爱，霍华德，谢谢你分享这一切。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请宽恕我，在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被赦免。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是蓝点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的数字内容制作人兼Z世代大师是艾米莉·布隆伯格，美术设计由约翰·莫罗完成。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你常用的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由乔什·拉德纳本人创作的《NYC》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
To subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, Order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasWriter.com slash novel, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
要订阅乔什·拉德纳在 Substack 上的 Muse Letters，请在 CraigThomasWriter.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的第一部小说，你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
了解本节目为先天性心脏病研究筹款的长期活动，看看如何发挥你的作用。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集节目由 Backyard Ventures 的支持倾情制作。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上确实会跳舞。